rochdale we've had rotherham now we've
got oxfordshire i'm not surprised by it
i don't think there's any doubt that
these types of crimes have been
committed in lots of different local
authority areas right across
the country what is disappointing is
that there's a similar pattern of
neglect in terms of dealing with the
issue and that's what we've seen whether
it's the police or whether it's uh
council officers uh having a particular
culture within their organizations
that's ignored these uh victims for too
long well yes and coffee why do you
think that the system has let these
girls down well i think it was very much
to do with attitudes to those children
by children's services and the police
the agencies that were there to protect
them they basically saw these children
as child prostitutes they basically saw
them as making choices and therefore
when those children tried to talk about
their experiences they were dismissed
and ignored and very much to do with a
very very bad culture in children's
services in the police david davis shows
that how you recognize it these girls
weren't believed they weren't taken
seriously and they seem to be a general
lack of understanding by
those they whose help they sought of
actually what was happening what was
going on this issue the whole issue of
consent didn't seem to understand it yes
i think that's absolutely right i think
those are the issues i think the most
telling lesson from the case is the case
that we've heard about today is the need
to listen to children to hear children
to view young people as children and
when we say listen to children not just
to hear their words but to hear them see
their actions as well well yes and and
how where does this come from because
one of the instances that's been picked
out in our reports there was a girl who
went to the police and she had blood all
over her and yet she was sent away i
mean
how much where does ignorance end i mean
this this does seem extraordinary
doesn't it i mean any kind of training
shouldn't shouldn't be needed for this
the details obviously the cases are
shocking as they always are shocking um
and i think that clearly we need to
ensure
that an oxygen have been very keen to
point out what they've done since the uh
since since the cases came to an end we
need to ensure that teenagers who are in
need are treated as children first and
foremost and and coffee would you say
there is a similarity between the
different areas the kind of behavior
that we've seen yeah so i mean a lot of
these reviews refer to a time before
2010 and i think without doubt before
2010 children were disbelieved there
were children who were systematically
raped and abused
and nobody listened to their experiences
and if they did they thought they were
just asking for it
but i think there's been a lot of
progress since 2010 there's an
increasing awareness about what sexual
exploitation and grooming is but i think
we need to need to do more and we need
to do more in engaging the wider
communities and the public in our fight
against tackling child sexual
exploitation simon sanchez at the
beginning you did say that you thought
this was an issue obviously these three
areas have been highlighted but you
thought it was a more widespread problem
than that would you agree that things
have changed or do you think that we
still do
no well these types of crimes will still
get committed there are perpetrators out
there that are intent on committing
these types of crimes and that's why the
agencies have to get better and i think
there has been there has been
improvements if you look at rochdale
there's been a revolution in terms of
improving children's services and child
and protecting children
very much better
service provision
but that has to be consistent right
across the country and i suspect some
authorities are still in denial and i'd
also make the point that ofsted who have
the job of regulating children's
services investigating whether they're
successful or not clearly failed in
rotherham probably failed in rochdale is
that regulator good enough to find out
what's going on in different local
authority areas which haven't been
exposed yet david thompson do you still
think that there are still in denial
well i think we
refer to offstead officer did publish a
report just earlier this year um
reviewing child sex exploitation across
a number of authorities and confirmed
that actually there were variable
practices in those different authorities
some very good practices keeping young
people safe but it wasn't consistent
across all the authorities that they
viewed okay and coffee what's your
reaction to david cameron's suggestion
today of making it a crime extending
this crime of willful neglect to people
that work in in services that are meant
to protect children will that make a
difference do you think how people work
i think it's a very strong message of
accountability and responsibilities very
strong message to senior managers and to
counselors that they should take an
interest in what is happening to
children in their area and they share
responsibility for making sure children
are protected and that sends a very
strong message about that and yet simon
danshuk were that the law now or had
been the law when these uh events went
on in oxford no one would have been no
that's true no one would have been
charged according to this report yeah
and i've been campaigning along with
others for the mandatory reporting of uh
child abuse and uh it's an important
step uh the governments are consulting
on this idea of uh willful a willful
neglect offense uh i wonder whether
they're setting the bar too high whether
it needs to be slightly lower so that if
people if professionals or officials
suspect child abuse then they have an
obligation to report it so the wording
of it will be absolutely critical they
have to get that right but i'm worried
that willful neglect is too high bar
david douglas how do you think it could
affect the job of social workers and
their recruitment as well do you think
they would worry that they'd spend more
time trying to be detectives rather than
doing the actual care work well i think
that's the worry but on the other hand i
think it's absolutely right that we
should have clear accountability
arrangements and i think within the
consultation period we have to work hard
to ensure that we've got the balance
right between um use of the law and
other means of accountability okay well
we must leave it there david davis show
simon danshek and coffee thank you all
very much indeed thank you